is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by the effervescent dr john
deloney right next to me best-selling
author and host of the dr john deloney
show you are not expecting effervescent
where are you that's one of besides um
stable
and um
relaxing that's the other word that
people used to describe me yeah you're
like a tums you know exactly i'm like a
walking xanax a bomb to the soul that's
your answer that's exactly right well we
are here to take your calls about life
money mental health relationships
boundaries lack thereof we are here to
help you take the right next step for
your life wherever you might find
yourself whatever is keeping you up at
night we want to help so give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five chris is kicking off this hour he's
in los angeles california chris welcome
to the ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call absolutely
my question is
is there ever a time when a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage loan would make more
sense than a 15 year
great question what is this a personal
situation you're walking through right
now
it is um so
my wife and i we have about
uh 200k uh gross income
uh our debt is about ten thousand
dollars on on one car
we have uh we have a two and a half year
old daughter
um we're maxing out our roth iras
um
we're contributing to our 529
and
i believe uh well with interest rates
going up we don't know you know where
they'll be in a few months but
i believe
we could afford a 15-year mortgage loan
it'll probably be right at about 25 of
our
take-home income
okay
but it doesn't really leave us
much margin for anything else um
chris what's your what's your car
payment yep
car payment 340 a month
would you have more margin if you had
340 a month extra
we would so why don't we go ahead and
pay off that car
uh should we just go ahead so we do have
six months emergency savings and then we
probably have a little bit
additional um but
we're thinking about doing a renovation
in the house
we're not going to go overboard but it
is somewhat of a fixer-upper
so you know
we we want to do the renovation
um
and also to answer the question um
our financial
uh advisor said you know a car well this
was the advice he gave us a few years
ago before kobe he said a car
depreciates in value so there's no point
in paying it all off at once find your
financial advisor today yeah
and if instead of that financial advisor
just go find somebody who's sitting at a
coffee shop and just ask them they're
going to be better advised than that
advice
this is
so chris here's the deal you're doing
chris's plan i'm not mad at you you're
do you're doing some great things you're
maxing out the roth the 529 you guys
have a great income but you're not doing
the ramsey plan and that's okay but if
you want to do our plan you got to pay
off all of your debt before we get on
the emergency fund before we go to
investing and you can save up and pay
for the you know put a good down payment
on this house and do it on a 15-year
fixed the 30-year loan is really a
shortcut that leads to you paying a
whole bunch more in interest i'm at 30
how old are you chris
my wife and i were 38. you're 38. if you
get a 30-year mortgage today you're
buying a coffin
and if you do a 15-year what i found and
this is based on actual data the people
following the ramsay plan end up paying
off their house in about seven years
now think about that you are then 45
years old
with a paid for house
and you still have another 20 years of
your working life where you have all of
your income back at your disposal your
greatest wealth building tool
hey i want to circle back
walk me through your financial advisor's
advice here
help me with this
he was saying uh so our interest on the
car is uh i don't know it's like three
percent
i think uh he was saying um oh invest
the difference and i can make you
millions right
like the markets are going to earn you
12 percent so you're just throwing nine
financial advisor you sound just like
them
here's where that's insane
you're paying a monthly payment against
a depreciating asset you see what i'm
saying so every month yeah
it's just not it's just you're paying
more interest while the car is worth
less and less and you're holding the
exposure so if you get fired
he's made his money on that gap
by being able to sell more of his
product to you and you're the one
holding the car note that you now
watch get towed away out of your
driveway
and so it's easy for him to say well
that's stupid you should float this
because he doesn't hold the other end of
the bag if something goes sideways and
it's easy to say nothing goes sideways
our whole job exists because things go
sideways um i hate to tell you this but
it doesn't sound like y'all are in a
position to buy a car i mean to buy a
home if your
mortgage
if you can only do it at this you're
gonna be so leveraged that you can't
breathe don't do it man it's not worth
it keep renting and i know that stings
yeah okay so
a couple of things with the 30-year
mortgage if we do have margin and then
we have bonuses and whatnot come in end
of the year
couldn't we apply that towards the
principle absolutely you could tell us
anymore 100 you could our data tells us
that 97 of people don't they can't
something comes up every month a thing
comes up or i want a thing or we need to
go somewhere a bonus becomes a vacation
and a new car instead of going towards
the principal and so this is where um
this is less of a math problem in this i
mean there is a math problem you're
going to pay infinitely more in interest
on a 30-year note
but this is a psychology problem and
this is just the human condition problem
that's why all these youtube scammers
who are like bro all you could do no
down [ __ ]
they can make do some some mathematical
gymnastics to make it work
but what we do is we sit with people
that the wheels have completely fallen
off which is millions and millions and
millions and millions of americans and
we say hey i know the math looks good
that's just not how we're wired and the
companies know this they wouldn't offer
it if it wasn't going to make them a ton
more money and so yeah you could in
theory you're exactly right
97 of people will not
one more thing let me just please
let me play devil's advocate absolutely
we do we do uh a 30 year and so we have
a little bit more margin assuming that
we'll we'll go ahead and pay off our car
okay you guys just the
recommended device uh 30-year and then
we have a margin um we might think about
having another kid or the other car
that's paid off it's got 150 000 miles
on it we don't know how much longer it's
going to last
um
i mean
so here's what you're here's what you're
doing
you are paying for those other things
with debt you're just rearranging it so
it's mortgage debt not
not card note debt
see what i'm doing
you're paying another one two three four
hundred thousand dollars on your
mortgage to have a little bit of
flexibility so you can buy a car in the
right now
you're just trading debt for debt
[Music]
you see what i'm saying
it doesn't sound like you're in a place
where you can afford a house right now
chris you guys make 200 000
let's do a budget let's figure out where
all this money is going and that will
help you create the margin not a 30-year
loan
you got this man this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality and
host of the fine print entree leadership
podcast joined today by dr john deloney
host of the dr john dolone show you can
check all of those shows out
on the ramsay network or wherever you
listen to podcasts open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number to call we'd be glad
to help you with any money issues
questions thoughts mental health
boundaries relationships you name it we
are here for you liz joins us up next
she's in great falls montana liz welcome
to the show
hi how are you we are doing great how
can we help today
um my husband owns a business
and
every year
around like this time and stuff it just
takes a little bit of time to
get his tax paperwork sorted and
everything i'm just really trying to
help but i kind of am starting to feel
like i'm nagging him
weekly bailey
you're kind of feeling like you're
starting to nag him or you're nagging
the crap out of him
i feel like i'm nagging the crap out of
him but
yeah i'm just trying to remind him to
stay on top of it so it's not a big
headache so i'm just i'm just reading
into the sound of your voice that this
is
not just about this business that you
are
tired of being his mother
thank you do you nag him in other areas
of life or is it just his business and
taxes
um
it's mostly just this
is mostly just more of the background
business stuff does he do his own
tactics and stuff
no we've got um
we've got somebody that will do them for
us every year oh so he won't even get
the receipts together and the paperwork
together and uh yeah
it's just doing that stuff
so what's the hold up
um
i think procrastination in adding to
what we already owe or
um you know
making that that number grow is he
scared of what the numbers are going to
be and what he's going to owe
yeah
um maybe i think so because we already
owe some which we fully understand that
we're working on
so
a lot of people think procrastination
and this is this is
i am if you look up the dictionary you
don't know what dictionary is to you
george um there are these thick books
that used to have uh definitions in them
i google it now yeah just google it if
you google the word procrastination my
face shows up okay so this is this is me
talking from experience here uh most
people think that procrastination is
about avoiding
doing something
about avoiding doing the thing the taxes
and it's not
it's about avoiding the emotions that
the action's gonna kick back on you okay
and so it usually in
my experience working with people and
experiencing myself it's an anxiety
response it is a i don't want
to feel what i'm going to feel when i
get into this
and it could be i don't want to get into
writing this paper because it's going to
pull me away from my kids i don't want
to get into these taxes because these
numbers are going to reveal that my
business is failing and that means i'm a
loser and i'm shameful et cetera so
procrastination often for the person
who's procrastinating isn't the problem
it's the solution to the problem it's a
way to avoid those that negativity
and
that doesn't help your
the wife because you're drowning right
you're trying to prop this whole thing
up um
is your business your your husband's
business failing is it struggling no
okay so what do you think he's hiding
from
what do you think he's avoiding
what feelings
i think the anxiety of
adding
to
what we
i already have do you guys have a lot of
debt
outside of that uh
or business day where's the irs
um
yes and then we've got some other debt
but we're already working the snowballs
so
um we just i also have to remind us that
it's more of a process and it's not
going to happen or be done tomorrow so
you guys already have irs debt in your
life
and so he's scared of adding to that
yes and so the head is in the sand just
going la la la la la let's just ignore
it it'll eventually go away i'll deal
with it another time but not today
so here's a magic sentence that my wife
and i sat down and had this conversation
years ago um i did not understand the
stress that my procrastinating things
and this is practical procrastinating
getting ready for church on sunday
mornings this is procrastinating getting
the garden done so that we can get stuff
planted i just i just stuff's gonna be
fine it'll be fine we'll get there we'll
get there but i didn't understand that
when she walks into church 15 minutes
late she feels completely exposed i had
no idea
um i didn't understand that two weeks
after planting season has a dramatic
effect six months later when the stuff
comes grows up right i didn't understand
that because i just was kind of la la on
my way through life
and so it took my wife sitting down and
having a hard conversation in direct
conversation about her needs when you do
this
i feel disrespected
when you are won't sit down and get this
thing done
i feel like you're choosing
to watch youtube videos and just go for
a jog
over the financial stability of our
family
and here's a line she came up to help
with that we both developed to help me
okay here's the line don't forget to
remember
here's the deal i will get out of my
truck and i'll have the lunch wrapper
and i'll have the my water bottle that
i've always got with me my my little
yeti here and i'll have my cds because i
still drive a car from the 1400s and
i'll have all my stuff and i'll just
leave it there i'll start to get out of
the car and she i'll start to go inside
and she will be on the front porch and
she'll say hey
don't forget to remember and what she's
telling me is
not hey pick up all your crap because
then i take that as a
um as
an attack what she's saying is hey don't
forget to remember how good it feels to
get into a clean car on your way to work
don't forget to how good it feels when
the taxes are finally done and you can
stare at that number then have a problem
to attack and so that number that that
phrase has been a gift in our home but
it only she could only do that when she
sat down and told him your needs and i
said hey man i'm tired of hurting you i
didn't understand that that my actions
were affecting you in this way
let's work on get on on on healing this
thing right so procrastination is no
longer a solution in my house it's
become the problem because i've
identified it as the problem and now i'm
going to jump i'm going to swan dive
into these problems and just get them
done and man my professional life has
benefited my marriage is better my
parenting is better all stuff's better
but that's the best you can do is have a
conversation about how this affects you
using i statements okay
and that's heavy and hard and i i know
that's hard and you know i don't hear in
your voice that you think this is gonna
work
ken there's been oh i
i guess i feel like we've had a lot of
those okay so
but
i i mean
i'm keeping at it just
trying to just maybe
articulate my words a little bit
differently to see if nope that will
help
so that's i think that can be a problem
don't dance on this one
okay
tell them use i statements this is how i
feel not what you're doing this is how
this affects me and let that be a um
don't dance don't try to soft pedal it
don't this is a hard conversation
because here's what's going to happen
you're going to be one inch away and
it's going to turn into two inches away
and then you're gonna run into somebody
at the office and they're gonna pay
attention to you and they're gonna grab
coffee for you when they're grabbing
theirs and you're gonna slowly go that
person gets it
and then you're gonna respond to the
text and you're gonna respond to the
phone call and all of a sudden you're
going to find yourself in a mess
it happens gradually bit by bit have the
hard conversation jump right in the
middle of this thing and
don't back down from it this is how this
feels to me
i'm asking you as your wife stop hurting
me stop hurting the kid stop hurting the
household operation
can you please make a commitment to not
forget to remember
that's hard yeah george when you're
having these needs conversations with
your spouse man the antidote to
procrastination i found is discipline
you just do it even when you don't want
to you just want to dive in even we
don't want to swan and so the irs you're
not going to get them off their back
this is the worst type of debt we put at
the top of the debt snowball for a
reason so you guys need to have some
urgency here get rid of this irs debt
once and for all work with a good tax
pro who can help you avoid ever going
into irs debt again maybe that's
quarterly estimated payments whatever
you guys aren't doing right now pay off
your consumer debt never look back it's
gonna change your marriage and your
relationship i promise you that thanks
so much for the call
join us triple eight eight two five five
two two five this is the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney
listen up teachers you guys are heroes
every single day you give your students
hope for their futures and because of
you over 5 million students have gone
through our foundations and personal
finance curriculum
in 48 of schools all over all over the
country and you guys deserve to be
recognized and that's why we're
celebrating you and teachers like you
during national financial literacy month
with our teacher appreciation giveaway
sponsored by borrowed future our hit
documentary about the dark side of the
student loan industry so teachers can
enter the giveaway today to win some
incredible prizes and two lucky teachers
will win five thousand dollars cash each
to use however they want and three more
teachers will win a thousand dollars
cash and there's more prizes where that
came from
so don't miss out teachers go to
ramseysolutions.com
teacher for your chance to win and tell
any teacher in your life that you know
and love that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash teacher
all right john so occasionally as i'm on
the internet i stumble upon an article
that
that i love you live on the internet i
do live there that is my zip code and uh
occasionally i find articles that i love
that i think would make you angry and so
those are the ones i want to read on air
great let's do you ready for the
headline john this sub's fun just so
america knows john does not know what's
about to hit him absolutely nothing no
idea what's coming bring it here's the
title love is in the air so is dander
on december 4th 2021 twixie and cowboy
both two-year-old brussels griffins were
married at the dallas home of the bride
twixie in the backyard
she wore an appliqued lace bodice with a
ruffle of layered tulle at the waist
george are these the groom i'm not done
john
the groom donned a handmade silk cotton
tuxedo and top hat later four-legged
guests enjoyed a meal of puppy chow from
vestal's catering in dallas as well get
this john as a puppuccino bar and
activities including a ball pit
the nuptials
cost about twenty five thousand dollars
what community was this in dallas your
home state john be proud
the two in their canines met at a
brussels griffin hangout in february
2021 the dog soon became boyfriend and
girlfriend no they didn't miss wilson
who handled the guest list said that she
and mrs hellwig intended to throw the
most epic dog wedding you know what i
guarantee you is in that community
hungry people
and dogs hungry dogs
puppy chow was provided we have entered
a tiny little vortex that we're not
going to be in much longer george where
we have more money and access to capital
than we have since i wish this was an
april fool's joke but this is from march
16th from the new york times oh gosh
so uh how do you feel about dog weddings
john i think we need to put that out
there cause i think we're gonna see more
of them happen
i think this show needs to be
sponsored by preparation h because i've
got hemorrhoids now
i cannot believe
i i just i didn't have the words for it
i don't even have words for it um i
don't believe in love for dogs um i love
can dogs find love nope they can't they
mate they mate george you wanna can i
get insulted
like
this is somebody living out a fantasy
that clearly didn't happen in their life
and they are putting it on their poor
dog you know what that dog was thinking
the whole time treat treat treat and
they said sit and the dog was not
thinking wow she looks beautiful coming
down the dog aisle he was just thinking
treat treat treat don't pee don't pee
don't pee treat that was it that was all
that was in that dog's head
and at one point when he was being
squeezed into the tuxedo he thought
i don't like my owner but treat treat
right that's it
you're telling me you don't want to see
those instagram pics
nope okay
you know i'd rather see i'd rather see
people uh giving money to a food bank
don't do that john
just enjoy life man can't people have
some fun
you're gonna get your uh your little
mutant dogs married aren't you that's
right i've got two french bulldogs but
technically they're related i feel like
i don't know
i'm not going to get them married
they're super not related insult to
injury because they're dogs and b they
came from different litters can i make
you even angrier
we saw this ad
that popped up someone sent it to me
from after pay here's what it said let
your fur baby say i do with after pay
which means you can now it's right there
on the screen from matching outfits to
snacks at the dog park reception you can
now pay off your pet wedding and four
interest-free installments with afterpay
there's no such thing as a pet wedding
here's this it's not a thing i don't
know if that was an april fool's joke
but i'm scared that it will become
reality
there's no such thing
there's no such thing as pet parents
you're you're pet owners and listen i
love my dog my wife had to have a talk
with me
about um when we got married
and i told her that dog was in my bed
long before you were right i loved my
dog i love my dog the dog i have now my
dog stella
is my ride or die dude
i get it
but i'm a pet owner i'm not a pet dad i
am though a human dad because i have
human kids and when they have weddings
you know what we're going to do we're
going to take human wedding photos and
we're going to throw human wedding rice
i don't know what we're going to do but
whatever they want to do
we're not going to throw
so i'm guessing my dogs are not invited
to your kids weddings and there will be
no puppuccino bar they were
not
that's offensive you know it's offensive
puppuccino
the people at starbucks are sad about
that what is a puppeteer it's fun they
just called it a puppetino if you go to
starbucks fun fact you have your dog or
if you don't you ask for a puppetino and
they give you a little cup of whipped
cream and it's a little treat for the
dog and it's called a puppuccino
i can get behind that that's all it is
no need to get angry i don't think we
need a puppuccino bar if it's just a can
of ready whip right that's true
spray it wow well uh the only insult
injury there john is not only are dog
weddings a thing but now you can go into
debt with buy now pay later for a dog
wedding
so i'm kind of this eternal optimist i
just think things are going to work out
people are going to come together
and there's i get these i get these
these shards of
of uh
apocalyptic sightings
and these are one of those moments where
you go it could all just come crying i
think i think it's coming coming down
and then by this afternoon i'll be good
to go and um then i'll see some young
kid texting and driving and i'll think
nah it's probably gonna come all down
and then uh somebody will send me a clip
of this actual conversation that you and
i are having about uh dog weddings
it's all coming i'm pretty sure it's in
revelation sign of the end times dog
weddings no it's the puppuccino that's
what it is chapter four versus wow wow
good times there john well i'm glad i
upset you mission accomplished and thank
you producer actually it's america it's
american everything's upsetting you
no just don't
i don't understand you it's fine john
let's get to the phones man no one wants
to hear about dog weddings anymore you
started okay poor danny danny is in
minneapolis what's up danny
hi how are you guys doing great how can
we help
so i'm currently reading the book
everyday millionaires and it sounds like
a lot of these millionaires have built
their wealth by contributing to their
company's 401k plan correct 79
yes and i just received a job offer
from a company who states that they have
a wide variety of investment options
available to the company's 401k plan
but they don't have a match
however they have an esop which is the
company contribution of stock annually
to my
personal esop account
and they state that this esop will
uh is more valuable over time the longer
i'm with the company so i'm just
wondering what your thoughts are on
having a company
have an esop instead of a 401k match if
i
should look into that more before
accepting the job offer
well i wouldn't decline the offer
because there's no match you can still
become a millionaire through your 401k
with a zero percent match that's okay
the match is fun it's a great bonus but
it sounds like you've got some stock
options with the company as well on top
of that they could be beneficial they
usually give it to you at a deal right
maybe 80 of cost
right something like that and then you
can cash that out every year you can
invest that money i wouldn't hang on to
the company stock just as its own
investment because i don't like single
stocks if this company goes under john
knows all about enron he can tell my mom
worked at enron danny where one of their
great things was how much company stock
they gave back and everyone was like wow
wow until they all woke up one morning
and it didn't exist anymore right and so
putting all your eggs in one basket is
just never a good investment strategy so
invest your 15 into your 401k
and that's where i would start and you
don't need to worry about the match uh
at this point now can i ask you this
danny
yeah um is there something else about
this company that you're not interested
in
[Music]
um
i'm just
trying to weigh the options um there you
go so
usually when we say like what about this
little thing that's a signal that the
bigger picture is is giving us
indigestion so go with your gut on this
one if it's not a place you want to work
then don't work there but don't not work
there just because of the match yeah
good call there john this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by dr john deloney we are
taking your calls about life money
mental health relationships you name it
we are here to help
mary joins us up next she is in fort
worth texas mary welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you so much for having me on i
appreciate it absolutely how can john
and i help well i have a question and i
hope it's a simple answer
so i have two boys one is already in his
second year in college away from home
and my second one is going to be
graduating in may
he has decided to attend community
college to
avoid debt
with that said
i totally support him with that with
that said his um
i'm recently remarried for about a year
um so my new husband feels that i sort
of baby him
and he feels that once he graduates in
may that i should be starting to charge
him rent i'm not totally in agreement
with that but i don't know if that's
just the mom in me saying that or um
does he have um
i guess a good a good side of it that
i'm not seeing
um i think we're conflating two separate
conversations here okay okay so one is
the skin in the game the kids going to
college the hey you're an adult now and
making adult decisions let's have adult
conversations that are going to be
different than we had when you're in
high school
the other is
your husband
your new husband saying hey
i think you um have a are babying this
young man
and so those it looks like they're the
same conversation they're not one of
these is a
um i want our household to look a little
bit different and i want these boys to
begin to grow up and then the other is a
business conversation you get the
difference there so
anytime somebody tells me that the their
their romantic partner gives them this
kind of feedback my first question is
always are they right
do you has your son let me put it this
way how long were you um were you
divorced previously did your husband
pass away yes okay no i was divorced for
about nine years okay can i ask you a
really hard question
sure did um one or both of those boys
help fill that gap that space
um as far as not having like a partner
during that time that's right
um
i i really would like to say no i like
to say that i treated them both of the
boys very equally
um my older one is a little bit more
like i want to go do my thing make my
decisions and i supported him to do that
um i i did
you know give him the suggestion of as
far as the school debt but um at the end
of the idea they can
let him make his own decision so
sometimes what i've seen over the years
is when somebody when there's a home
with divorce let's say and i'm just
picking that out of the blue because you
and i are talking um i'm using an
example because you are talking
there's some sort of parental guilt that
they
will try to um extricate from the
relationship by over helping with one of
the children okay or both of the
children i'm gonna give you what you
need sure you can do this sure i'll be
there for you sure i'm not gonna miss
any games i'm gonna i i'm gonna try to
backfill this hurt with all this other
stuff
and i'm wondering is that what your new
husband is calling out
um to be honest i'm not sure
um
sometimes he'll make comments as far as
like the chores he does or as far as me
asking my son to um
contribute
i'll be honest i um i my son works um so
i i do provide him um an allowance until
he graduates
um
but as far as him asking me for
expensive things he doesn't really ask
me for anything
um
so i don't i don't know if i'm missing
something i don't know if it has to do
with the route he had as far as his
childhood or am i just
really babying my son well so i think i
think that's two different conversations
so i think you s you tell your husband
hey you said that i'm babying him and
this is going to be a boundary
conversation for your new marriage tell
me more what are you seeing that i'm not
seeing because over the last decade i've
been by myself on my own i've been doing
my best to try to love these two boys
and i'd love your feedback because
you're a grown man i'd love your
feedback now we're entering into a tell
me more conversation that's not gonna be
no i'm not issue or no i'm not right so
that's number one number two
um in fact before we before this column
came in george and i just happened to be
talking about this earlier today on off
air i think there's several ways to
approach the
rent conversation the
you know should you pay into it my
friend mike his dad had a great thing
that a suggestion that i loved he just
sat down when mike graduated college and
said hey you get six months rent free
you you can cash it in over the course
of your adult life
and he was like all right cool and so he
lived the first month after he graduated
and his dad came in and goes five left
and he's like oh oh you mean like and
he's like yep i mean for so
here's here's the important thing it's
set in boundaries it's setting very very
clear here's my expectations you can
live rent free for one year and then
we're going to charge you 500 a month
you got to get a job or we're going to
charge you rent out of the gate i think
all however you all do that the
important thing is that you have very
clear boundaries with time deadlines on
them with responsibilities with if
you're going to live in this house you
still have to come home at midnight
whatever y'all want to do it's the
messiness and the all over the placeness
that just wrecks relationships george
what do you think yeah i just think
having those ground rules in place is
going to be key whether or not you
charge them rent or not i still want
ground rules and i want to know what the
exit strategy looks like is this ten
years or is it six months it can't be
extended high school exactly so i think
as long as he's working he's working a
job i don't think there's nothing wrong
if you want to charge him a little bit
of rent you know give him a taste of
what adult life is gonna be
because he's gonna have a payment like
that to factor into his budget and so
maybe you say hey what are your
financial goals great here's the
agreement you're gonna live here but
you're gonna build the emergency fund
you're gonna start investing you're
gonna save up that down payment whatever
that looks like let's have a go for why
we're doing this and here's what else i
love i would love your new husband to be
a part of this because this is half his
house too
and so i want him to be a part of
setting the ground rules for the home
that your son is going to choose to live
in after he graduates high school
so he's going to talk to both of you
this isn't going to be the side deal
between son and mom that you're going to
try to go pitch to
your new husband
everybody's going to be in the room so
that your new husband can say my
expectation is fine i'm going to give
you a year rent free here you will do
the yard you will help with the light
bill you whatever those are going to be
and again that's a separate it's almost
a business transaction if you would of
course it's your son and all that but
this is a
how would we approach this from a
business angle
the other conversation is hey this is a
broader picture you see of me and how i
interact with my loved ones
it's going to impact your marriage
that's a different conversation that i
really want you all to have but thank
you so so much for that call yeah how
does that sit with you mary
um
it is a another way to look at it to be
honest um i really didn't think about um
having a meeting with all all three of
us and really seeing i mean i like the
part that you shared where um you know
it's part of being an adult so that is a
good way to definitely look at it thank
you for the feedback you got thank you
so much for loving your son man that's
fantastic good stuff that's on your new
marriage yeah this is a big one john
parents are dealing with this and
especially millennials there's a
sandwich generation who's dealing with
the kids are still at home but i'm also
trying to take care of my elderly
parents and when you add debt to all of
that it creates a mess and so the best
thing you can do is have that the
financial discipline in place and
it sounds like he went to community
college to avoid debt which i love now
if he was strapped with debt and he was
like mom i'm broke and i got to live
here it's a different situation well and
sometimes kids do the math and and
they're great at it right they'll sit
down he probably sat down with a
spreadsheet and said i can go to this
community college i can get these
classes do this much it's going to cost
me this great
but they don't factor in
the cost of being alive right and being
alive is expensive the cost of being
alive sounds like a great book title
it's expensive right yeah and so the
cost of being alive right now is rent
and
insurance and cell phone and all these
other things
and so all of every family does it
differently a friend of ours their their
oldest daughters got married and was
like hey i'm gonna buy a new car he's
like good this is a good time for you to
call the insurance company right and by
the way what you do with that cell phone
now you're gonna be married some people
wait till then some people that as
they're graduating high school sit down
and say all right here's what's gonna
look like the next five years you're
gonna go to college we're covering
tuition you're gonna pay but it's all
about that hard
conversation you've got to have it
otherwise it ends in messy you don't
love me you never and you're like i gave
you ever it's just stop all that yeah
have the hard conversation and the worst
thing you can do as a parent is you let
them go into adulthood because you were
you know trying to take care of them and
cover every single bill and they go wait
i got how much is insurance what is get
oh my goodness i had no idea how much
life costs and so the sooner our kids
can learn that the better and that's why
i'm excited about a personal finance
curriculum that's in high schools
because kids are going oh i learned this
stuff now before it's too late right or
before i got thrown into the deep end of
the pool right yeah good stuff there
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to my co-host dr
john deloney all the folks in the booth
keeping the show afloat and you america
we appreciate you tuning in we'll be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your
relationships
your mental health
right in front of you that's what we're
here for i'm george campbell joined
today by dr john deloney open phones
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five ryan's kicking off
this hour he's in cleveland ohio ryan
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you how are you great how can we
help
so this is a pretty open-ended question
but i'm trying to figure out how i
decide my next financial goal and i
guess more specifically how do i change
or maybe pause my investing to achieve
whatever goal there might be wow okay so
you're pretty familiar with the baby
steps i assume
uh yes i like i've i've read through um
the book and i'm vaguely familiar with
them but it's been a little while
honestly so what are your goals man what
are you trying to accomplish
that's that's the hard part because i'm
very very fortunate right now to have no
debt i have a pretty good income for i
mean i'm 23 fresh out of college uh and
right now i've just been focusing on
investing for retirement so i've maxed
out my roth already this year and now i
just have income to put towards
something and it feels wrong to not just
invest all of it but at the same time
like i might be considering getting a
home at some point so you know there's a
down payment there i'm not really sure
okay what's your income
um it's most likely going to be
somewhere between about 60 and 80 this
next
year for 2022. okay uh pre-tax do you
have an emergency fund in place of three
to six months of expenses
yeah i've got 7 500 saved up for my
emergency funds great
and how much are you investing
percentage-wise right now you said
you're maxing out the roth so i assume
not quite 15 percent
yeah i've looked at the last few months
and it's come to more close to about 30
to 33
that of your income is what you're
investing
uh yeah i believe so unless my numbers
are wrong but yeah the loose sales
okay well once you max out that roth
that puts you what six thousand
uh yes yep so i hit six thousand last
month for my roth and which is about ten
percent of your income but it sounds
like you're you're kind of front loading
you're putting a lot of money from each
paycheck right now but once you max that
out what are your other retirement
investment options do you have one
through your employer
i don't have any 401k options i work
with a small business
so i don't really have any other
retirement options unless i open up like
a traditional rock or something like
that as far as i'm aware of
well yeah there's no traditional roth
see a traditional ira or roth ira
traditional ira correct okay well if you
max out the roth that's going to be it
for the year on the ira side but there
are other options taxable brokerage
accounts things like that where they
won't be tax advantage but you can
invest and pay taxes on it when you take
it out so as far as financial goals you
told me you want to get a house and so
my next goal if i'm in your shoes
debt-free with an emergency fund is
getting a big house down payment saved
yeah now how i guess i'm struggling with
how do i save up a down payment um
and adjust my investment strategy for
that because i i guess i kind of view it
as i could always just throw a bunch of
money into a brokerage fund and
uh you know choose a safe-ish investment
and then when i buy a house i buy a
house with that money
but of course there's always risk with
investment so it's down you know well
when it comes to that kind of risk i
like a longer time horizon so if you're
saying hey i don't need a house the next
year or two i'm looking at three fives
years from now then i'm okay with you
putting some money into those types of
accounts to invest because you can you
can ride that out and if you have
patience and you're not at do you don't
have a level of urgency then you'll
you're going to be okay annual
investments will grow you know who knows
with this market but you can grow eight
nine ten eleven percent if the market
gets back up to where it was
right right okay so that's what i'd be
doing in your shoes just start investing
15 of every paycheck into whatever
options you have right now it sounds
like the roth ira is your best option uh
beyond that you're not gonna have a ton
with because you don't have an employer
retirement plan but you can invest in a
taxable brokerage account maybe in some
index funds and park the money there as
you save up for the house and ryan can i
give you one more little nugget to put
in your back pocket
please yeah um you can do three things
with money you can save it
you can spend it or you can give it
make sure you're planning for the future
you're doing a great you're you're so
far ahead of 95 people we talked to
me included okay you're way down the
road
um it took me about 15 or 20 years to
get to the financial position you're in
okay
but
make sure you enjoy your life your 23.
okay go have fun go to a concert hang
out with people go somewhere right you
see what i'm saying enjoy some of that
money and start a
start a habit start a an identity
of generosity
once a once a week once a month tip
somebody out of their mind give to your
local church if you go to one
find ways that you can invest and give
back to your local community make that a
part of who you are okay and that's one
of those legacy shifting you'll you'll
change your family tree with the the
spirit behind which you deal with your
money okay
yeah thank you so much i appreciate the
advice you got my brother yeah thanks
for the congratulations great reminder
there john you know a lot of uh young
people out there they're very focused on
investing and i love that young people
are even excited about this it's so cool
but to your point we can get so far down
the rabbit hole of what the next big
investment is and get rich quick
scheming crypto and nfts and we forget
to just live our lives so what i love
about our plan is we say invest 15
percent
and you'll be a millionaire yeah if you
do that over consistently over a long
period of time pay your household not
invest every single time you can and not
spend a dime and no don't do anything
else you got to live your life yeah
there's other things along the journey
that you've got to be thinking about
and when it comes to investing i invest
you know i love i love talking about
money i love financial topics but we
also need to enjoy ourselves and my wife
is like hey we haven't been on vacation
in a long time i'm like oh yeah we
should we should do that too well and i
i
come from a home we didn't have a lot
right and money was a stressor for us
and so i have it continue to loop on the
story that this is all going away and
this is finite and
so i'm having to work hard
in a season like you know we're in a
season of blessing right now
hey yes we're trying to crush the the
house mortgage we're trying to do this
take your wife on a 20th anniversary
good god dude what do you do right buy a
car that runs right and so i have to
talk to myself
and let myself know hey we're following
the principles we're okay how do you
balance that mentality cause there's one
side that says
yolo you know like we're gonna live
forever we'll figure it out later let's
just do what we want right now and
there's another side that is the like
this is all gonna come crumbling down
tomorrow i think there's two you have to
be it depends on what side of the coin
you're on if you owe somebody else money
that's an emergency it's danger will
robinson you is not time for yolo it is
time to stop everything and get that
done
when you get to zero you owe nobody
anything you have an emergency fund so
not if but when the things go wrong you
you are able to deal with it
that's when you have to exhale and say
tell yourself and you have to practice
this not in danger anymore
now it's about giving it's about living
it's about saving it's about planning
and it's about looking at that beautiful
wife and saying hey let's go do
something fun it's about looking at that
guy who doesn't who looks like he's
rubbing two paintings together eat that
meal i got this for you my brother right
it's it's you're able to live a
different kind of life because you're
not running for your life anymore oh
mic drop moment there yeah good stuff
more of the ramsey show coming up give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
dolone and we are taking your calls
john we're about to head back out on the
road
it's been a dry spell we have not been
in front of a lot of people and i'm
super pumped that we are headed to
dallas texas your home state saturday
october 22nd a jam-packed arena filled
with people ready to experience what it
means to live life to the fullest this
is all of the ramsey personalities
together on stage we're like the power
rangers
but cooler somehow i'm going to strongly
disagree you do run around with spandex
a lot backstage my skinny jeans have
been considered spandex scientifically
you are the denim power ranger aside
from that we're going to empower you
with tools and principles to create
unstoppable momentum in your life the
event is smart conference and we're
super pumped that's saturday october
22nd it's been three years since we've
done this event and we're pumped to
bring it back headlining speakers
include myself dave ramsey rachel cruz
dr john deloney ken coleman and
christina ellis plus we've got special
guests craig and amy grochelle from life
church they're going to be joining us
talking about marriage
you don't want to miss this this is just
one pack day we're going eight to five
drinking from the fire hydrant practical
advice from leading experts on money
personal growth leadership mental health
career and this is not just a pep talk
you're not just going to learn things
we're going to have a great time tickets
start at just 39 bucks
full day event for 30. if anybody's
worried we actually will not be drinking
from the fire hydrant but from the hose
maybe both we don't know yet nope okay
probably not probably not and another
thing um this is throwback to another
segment we did earlier
we will not be leaving smart conference
to attend yet another dog wedding no
puppuccino bar all right good there will
not be well if you want to see john
shamey publicly on stage come join us
for smart conference october 22nd full
day on a saturday man it really is it's
my favorite event that we do if there's
people in your life you're like you want
to introduce them to the ramsay plan
this is the event for them you get a
taste from all of our speakers for just
39 bucks get your tickets now before
they sell out ramsey solutions.com
events
all right luke joins us up next he's
ain't st louis luke welcome to the show
hey guys how are you good how are you
i'm doing pretty good um my question is
how do i build credit
without going into debt because i know
uh and being able to afford like you
know a car and a house and stuff like
that
sure
why do you want to go where's this
coming why do you want to build credit
man
oh well you know i just i'm looking to
buy a new vehicle
and eventually get a house so
and i know that they are
our current societies full of like uh
you know you can just finance everything
you can does it mean you should
no all right
so luke let me put it this way if you
saved up
how old are you and uh what how much do
you make right now
uh i'm 18 and i make about
two thousand dollars a month okay two
thousand dollars a month how much margin
do you have do you live with your
parents
oh yeah okay is there any pressure from
them to build credit
uh a little bit yeah yeah they want me
to get like a credit card and stuff to
in order to help build it
well here's what i found
i purchased my last car
in cash
and i didn't need a credit score because
i paid in cash so the only reason you
need a credit score is to go into debt
and if you follow our plan you've
decided to take that off of the table
and we figure out another way we have
diligence we have patience we're going
to save up over time and buy that car
when we can and it's going to be a
reasonable car we don't need to go out
getting a 35 000 car with payments at 18
years old
and then when it's time to buy a house
there's a special type of mortgage you
can get that uh or it's a special kind
of underwriting process the mortgage is
the same
and they work with you specifically if
you have a credit score of zero but you
have a history of handling money well
because your credit score is just a
score on how well you dance with debt
has nothing to do with how wealthy you
are and how you handle your money
okay
so luke i want i'm going to give you
some homework you're going to go listen
to the fine print podcast and i did this
episode called the dirty truth behind
your credit score where we unpack every
single facet of the credit industry what
your credit score is made up of spoiler
alert it all involves debt and i talk
with mortgage experts about how to do
this and i'll tell you luke i did this
myself so this is from personal
experience
i got my last mortgage that is now paid
off
using manual underwriting using what's
called a no score loan and what they do
it's real old-timey they look at your
actual financial picture stop it george
i know madness so you show them like i
don't know your utility payments and
they show them your income and you show
them your w-2s and your tax returns and
they go okay i think luke is gonna he's
gonna be able to pay this loan back
we'll go ahead and give them this loan
and so that's what i did luke and it's
possible and let me tell you it was what
eight years without a credit score and
it's going to dwindle away soon because
i just paid off my house and i don't
miss it and not once when i'm renting a
car renting out you know getting a hotel
room i have not run into issues with the
credit score and look i want you to hang
on the line uh kelly's gonna send you a
copy of dave's total money makeover and
you're 18 years old i want you to read
it cover to cover
and it's going to give you the why
behind why we tell you what to do and
it's going to give you a step by step
how to do this you're 18 you're about to
start having to make grown-up decisions
and we want you to get you
once you set you off on the right foot
thanks for the call appreciate it man
brett is in aitkin south carolina he's
joining us up next brett welcome to the
show
hey guys thank you very much
today
yeah i'm calling today i uh
i'm 28 years old just got my first uh
really you know good paying job doubled
my salary
and we are still on
step two of paying off our debt we have
a bit um
but
my wife she really she has anxiety she's
on medicine
but the thought of having less than ten
thousand dollars in our savings account
really makes her anxious okay how would
you recommend i pay off the debt we have
while finding this balance with my
wife's anxiety
the anxiety
circling around that that dollar amount
is not related to the dollar amount
it's related to a story or a narrative
that her body's responding to
so
when people most of the time not always
not always most of the time anxiety
results from a
being amongst people or disconnected
from people it's a relationship issue
it's your body sounding an alarm that we
are disconnected from relationships or
we're unsafe in relationships or
somebody finds himself unsafe
which is a perspective she holds right
now or they're in a situation where they
have no control people who owe other
people money it doesn't surprise me that
their bodies bring the anxiety alarms
because they're not safe right there are
a few things a few little moments away
from being in a mess right
really what we need to sit down and do
is get to the heart of the anxiety issue
and it's less about the dollars and it's
more about um
how can she feel safe in her own body it
may be we have to compromise here it may
be hey tell me what this ten thousand
dollars is going to buy you or it's
going to save us from
and then let's talk about here's the
math here's we're gonna start right so
this is a big full picture but this is
about healing connection this is about
healing safety this is not about trying
to stumble into a dollar amount you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's great okay so circle back to
her here's your homework assignment
circle back to her and i'm gonna hang on
the line i'm gonna send you two copies
of my book redefining anxiety it's
really thin
and y'all can read it together and it's
a reframing of anxiety okay um but
here's what i want you to do i want you
to sit down tonight not talking about
dollars not talking about sense i want
you to say
i want to start being doing a better job
of meeting your needs here at home
i want to start doing a better job of
helping you feel safe
would you do me the honor
it's not sexy it's not how hollywood
writes it up would you do me the honor
of giving me five to ten things and you
can think about it
write them down for me these make me
feel loved these make me feel safe and
for my wife it's chit chat dude it is
chit chat i just want you to sit at the
table when i'm doing stuff and just talk
to me about whatever and i think man we
could be using this time so much more
productively
chit chat or it might be hey would you
just when you walk through the kitchen
if there's a dish in the sink will you
just grab it and drop it in the um
in the
dishwasher for me
will you just hold my hand when you wake
up in the morning before you jump out of
bed and run to the gym it's little
things like that that suddenly create an
ecosystem of
and that body goes we're safe now i
don't have to sound the anxiety alarms
yeah that money in the bank with a pile
of debt on the other side is an illusion
of safety that's right we need real
safety which is getting out of debt
getting the emergency fund in place so
let's get a plan together let's approach
that do the baby steps and you will have
true financial she's lucky to have you
brother this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney
and in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage tyler joins us
what's going on tyler what's going on
i'm having a great time how about you
guys good so i assume you're dead free
apparently i am we love to see it okay
where are you from
i'm originally from massachusetts but
currently i live in the orlando area in
florida very cool okay so let's talk
about this debt how much did you pay off
86 000 15
86 that 15 is what really gets you
that's right wow how long did this take
that was the two chick-fil-a meals you
had to have didn't you sorry about that
no i uh
started in december 2017 through
december 21 so 48 months awesome
okay and what was your range of income
during this time started at 61 000 ended
at 88 000. 61. what do you do for a
living dude i'm a transportation
engineer for a
consulting firm in florida okay can i
ask you a hard question let's hear it
what does that mean what does that mean
um well i think at the root of it what
it means is i'm part of a team that
looks to
help develop communities to be places
you want to drive to and not through oh
and i love roundabouts you should put
that on the t-shirt you love roundabouts
wow i call those little cuss circles but
i good good i'm good i'm glad i'm glad
you have them awesome man so tell me
about this 86 000 15 what kind of debt
was this yeah so 46 000 of that was
undergrad student loans principal
another 10 000 was interest i paid
between the private and federal loans
fun and then 30 000 was my car wow when
i walked across the stage when i
graduated with my masters i didn't take
in on any debt when i got my master's
degree i got a full ride
but when i walked across that stage that
was about 75 thousand dollars i had wow
and yeah and you had this car what kind
of car was this it was a forward fusion
and you still have it today still have
it all paid off got the title and
everything in the mail drives different
now doesn't it it does awesome a little
bit lighter so 48 months ago that's a
pretty long time to slog through this
what got you started on this journey
how'd you get connected yeah so
something i've come to realize is
sometimes you don't even know that
you're on the journey
when i started paying off the car
immediately and then i have my student
loans start you know six months after
you graduate
as i was paying them off i was late 2018
early 2019 i did a little bit of math
i'm an engineer so i've got to do a
little bit of math and i found that i
had paid about 9 000
towards my student loan debt
but only two thousand dollars had come
off of the
principal principle
man
and when i did that i was like i don't
know about that something's got to
change and my father said have you ever
heard about dave ramsey
i was like dave ramsey i think i've
heard the name and he's like well you've
got you've got to start listening to him
you got to get his book you got to do
all this stuff i'm like all right dad
you've taught me a few things so we'll
try this too
got his book i read it i was like wow
this is this actually like really lays
out the best way i can possibly get out
of this and then from there and i was
already making bigger than minimum
payments but i went all out talking
about any bonus any extra pay anything i
could do
went towards that debt wow
number one no kid listens to their dad
good dad and two wow so you went all in
so i i this was this was music to your
engineering heart right a simple laid
out plan oh yeah let's just walk down
this road absolutely
absolutely i think one of my favorite
moments of the whole journey was july
2020.
i uh when the vets had suspended the
interest rates i still had sally mae
hanging out with me
and i paid her off in july 2020 got rid
of her and now
i had the rest of my federal in the car
and i got rid of that this last december
so that's awesome yeah and every day
there's a new headline
is it gonna be paused is it gonna and
you're thinking i don't care yeah that
was one of the things just just
yesterday they extended it but at this
point i don't have to worry anymore
that's so good that's so great so out of
all the things that are involved with a
journey like this what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
discipline
absolutely discipline sticking to a plan
i there's a little quirky thing about me
maybe it's because i'm an engineer i
don't know but i usually well i have
this notebook at home this big master
notebook
and about every month i sit down i write
down every single thing about my money
my finances to the cent and i go through
and i write down i actually write down
on paper no computer just on piece of
paper i go through exactly what's going
on where all the money is going and i
figure that out
every single month on paper oh
yeah you don't have a home for every
dollar you have a home for every cent
yeah
that's an engineer right there that is
an engineer wow so this is real talk i
interviewed jocko this morning and we
were talking about discipline equals
freedom and i was connecting with me
with all the money principles we have
and he said financial discipline will
get you to financial freedom
and that's exactly what you did by
following this proven plan and that's
what you needed you just needed
something aimat and a plan to do it oh
absolutely that's exactly how it would
characterize it wow that's incredible
we're so proud of you man do you have
any cheerleaders that were with you
along this journey oh absolutely my wife
metia has been there for me uh my
parents uh paul and vicky absolutely
i've had uh plenty of co-workers family
friends who've been there listen to me
hear what everyone has to say and i went
forward and and i did it
can i ask you a hard question um and
it's not hard in the math sense it's
hard in the existential sense
there's something about
your graduate student you've got a
degree in engineering you're serving
your community you're doing good stuff
you're making great money
um
you live in a you have a home you live
in a home apartment apartment okay so
you live in apartment
there's something about
rolling up to that job with your those
co-workers with that pedigree
in a forward focus
and it's fun
and you roll up and they all look at you
and go oh
what are you doing
how do you how would you coach somebody
who's like man i just feel like my car
sticks out in the parking lot where i
work
well yeah like i don't have the tesla
yet i guess right but i um
no but uh what i would i think the best
way to put it is something my dad would
say which is you need a car to get from
a to b oh yeah and uh i plan on keeping
that car until can't drive anymore and
so the the meta is i don't care
no right i don't care she loves me my
dad loves yeah exactly
everyone a lot of people love me so it's
all good ah it's so wow so when did you
get married
march 19th a few weeks ago oh my
goodness oh so you're in it now yeah
right here wow
let's get her up there matia you want to
come on up
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you that's dave's
best-selling book and it's the next
chapter of your story especially as
newlyweds now uh it's so awesome i'm
excited to read it oh you're gonna love
it it's gonna inspire you uh along the
journey because it's a long one now you
did the hard work and this four years
now this is about the next 10 15 20
years as you guys build this amazing
life together and we're gonna give you a
copy of the total money makeover the
book that got you started maybe you can
get one of these engineer knuckleheads
who's playing around with some debt and
go hey man here's a proven process
here's how i did it when they started
asking yeah
well you're awesome man we're proud to
have you guys and matia of course now
your biggest cheerleader as you've
completed this journey it's tyler
all the way from the orlando florida
area 86 015
paid off in 48 months making 61 up to 88
thousand dollars count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two one
we're debt-free
[Music]
and just like that was another
engineering uh an engineering debt free
screen he did what he needed to do we're
dead free that's true that's right
incredible man man this gets me pumped
and this is this is what i want john for
everyone listening out there
at some point in the process you have to
decide if you're a financial genius
who's broke or if you're going to follow
a proven plan and a lot of us out there
were like we're figuring it out we're
great at debt management we're moving
the zero percent interest card to this
card up we got 17 cards we're getting
our cash back and we're like we're
winning and yet we go to bed with
anxiety we don't sleep our bodies
beating a drum inside of us going hey
get back on you're not safe wake up
we're not okay right and at some point
you've got to decide okay george's plan
is not crushing it what if we try this
plan over here and it's not because
we're so amazing and so smart we've just
found that it works like 10 million
people have done it works
one thing that nobody in the financial
space can say is
what my thing is 100 foolproof and this
one is if you do it if you go all just
do it
every single time if you go ish you're
going to get ish results right but if
you go all in and you go gazelle intense
i'm getting the second job the third job
i'm selling everything that's not tied
down that has dust collecting on it i'm
gonna do this plan and i'm gonna do it
right the results are there it's
incredible every time i love it well
we're pumped for tyler and mattia debt
freedom is on the other side folks you
can get there tyler did it you can too
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
eight
seven
six
five
four
three
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the ramsey show i'm george
campbell ramsay personality and host of
the fine print and entree leadership
podcast joined today by best-selling
author and all-around good guy dr john
dolone i agree there we go i agree on
something finally
well our
question of the day comes from
blinds.com their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you mismeasure
or pick the wrong color as john and i
tend to do they will remake your blinds
for free get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
single month you'll save even more just
use the promo code ramsay to get the
best deal
today's question comes from rose
do you think she could have uh leo could
have fit on the door 100 yeah
no question leo could have fit on the
door that's for another day another day
all right today's question comes from a
different rose in arkansas not carrying
the heart of the ocean she asks my
husband is on a second kidney transplant
and is a stay-at-home parent with our
two kids i work full time and we're on
baby step three
i've asked my husband multiple times to
get life insurance
he refuses and says it's a scam
i have insurance on myself for him and
our kids he thinks i should invest the
money we spend on his life insurance so
it will grow
i'm the nerd and take care of all
finances and goals he agrees and just
goes with what i've been learning and
growing from
i've shared my fears with him because he
has been near death many times
what can i do to help him see the big
picture um
there's multiple
questions in here yeah there's a lot
going on here um
i don't love that you're just taking
care of all the finances and goals and
he just goes along with it and then when
he doesn't like it he just disagrees
we've got to be more on the same page
yeah our whole financial plan there is a
c
this is heartbreaking
um
there is
it's common but when
one spout one man when one spouse you
know husband wife whoever um
has multiple health issues and is
reduced uh unable to go find purpose and
meaning in their work
it can be a hard transition to purpose
and meaning finding at home
and this is men and women husband i
don't care who it is and
the word that comes to mind here that is
it is scary because it has a lot of
negative connotation to it and a lot of
mental health challenges to it is this
idea of burden i'm a burden yeah i would
be better if i wasn't here so stop
putting money aside for me you all do
this i'm already dragging you down
enough right
like i'm not i'm already hurting
everybody just by still being here right
second kidney transplant this is a
household full of heartbreak this is a
household full of trauma this is a
household that has lost trust in his
body this is a this is a lot going on
here
and this is a wife who's at the end of a
rope she's scared she's tired she's
lonely and she just wants him to love
himself as much as she does and he
doesn't yeah and here's the
heartbreaking thing you can't make
somebody do that and it just stinks man
it's really um yeah it's hard hard hard
now on the financial side let's talk
about this idea that life insurance is a
scam
he's partially right because there's so
many terrible life insurance products
out there especially in the whole life
the cash value world and so the only one
we recommend is term life now i don't
know his whole health picture i don't
know how easy it's going to be for him
to get term life there are situations
where you can get term life after having
a kidney transplant but they're going to
be asking some follow-up questions was
it kidney failure what was the
circumstances leading up to it and it's
going to be it's going to be expensive
and it'll be more expensive but is it
still going to be worth it yes and is
term life going to be astronomically
cheaper than any other kind of whole
life policy yes can you invest the
difference and still do your investing
yes but i want you to keep your
insurance's insurance your investments
as investments and that's why i hate
whole life insurance so get in touch
with our friends at xander insurance
they can walk you through the process
shop around all the top companies all
over the country and try to get you the
care that you need but he has to care
first right and here's an important um
the the natural question here is this
i'm not making any money
so there's no money to replace here so
we don't need life insurance on me you
spouse you wife you husband whoever
you're making all the money
there's no
there's no reason to have money on me
and what i would say here is he's a
stay-at-home parent he's got they got
two kids if he was to die today she's
gonna have to come up with money to
replace that right and so it might not
be the full 10x salary and all that
but you need to put something away i've
got much more life insurance on me than
my wife does right she's she stays at
home right now she's got some side
businesses at home but she stays at home
i'm going to have to get some help if
she were to pass away
i had to get a lot of help right
multiple people but my salary pays our
bills and so we have more insurance on
me because that's going to be a that's
going to be a harder hit we need to keep
the lights on right um and so
it might be different it might be the
the scale may be different um and here's
where this gets hard george and we see
this a lot and when
people are struggling
he's partially right as you mentioned
some some some life insurance is a scam
um you don't have any salary to replace
so why are we even doing this i am a
burden yeah it's hard it's hard
and we can get focused on that we get
locked in on the negative side of this
let's look to the other side of this
thing right and i'll tell you brother i
don't even know your name
i'm going to tell you this
yes you've had some medical challenges
yes you've had some some rough stuff
you're worth taking care of yourself
you're worth being loved you're worth
being the parent to these two beautiful
little kids
and it's time for you to look in the
mirror and say i'm worth standing up and
healing two different people have given
a kidney for you
i'm gonna i'm gonna make meaning of this
thing i'm gonna live into the gift i've
been given twice now and i'm gonna rise
above this stuff okay and that's a hard
conversation to have but it's time to
stand up and get after it okay yeah good
reminders and great reminder for
stay-at-home parents that you need life
insurance too yeah we always recommend
that because you've got to hire mary
poppins if something happens that's
right you got it and we get a lot of
calls and people are going child care is
astronomical yeah we know i have to hire
someone to do all that and all the other
things around the house not just child
care there's a lot going on there so
make sure that you have insurance to
replace that income good stuff there
from john uh while we're on this topic
john this a lot of calls that i have
played into
this idea of your new book own your past
change your future yeah there's a lot of
trauma out there people are going
through a lot of hard things and what i
love about this book is it's not just
for people who have deeply traumatic
experiences this is a book for all of us
right who've experienced some level of
something over the course of our lives
and uh i'm really excited about this
book it feels like we're just days away
right yes it's uh april april 19th it's
still in pre-sale and you still get all
the great things that come along with it
but it hits the streets it's the stores
um april 19th so i i had i was in an
interview today and i had this thought
um
this book in this book i i follow my
story right i walk alongside people
talking about what's happening to our
culture talking about what's happening
in their lives and also here's what i
experienced so i've been there too
and you see somebody like dave who the
it's an implosion bankruptcy
that's not most people
most people are
quietly the living lives as they say of
quiet desperation they're slowly
drowning they're slowly running out of
oxygen it's just like a blanket slowly
being laid over them and i didn't end up
in rehab i didn't burn my house to the
ground i didn't cheat on my wife but i
just lived with this low-level home of
anxiety and depression and i guess this
is just the way this is and i guess we
just gained an extra five pounds every
year and i guess we just our intimate
lives just slowly fade away and my knees
hurt my back hurt and that's that's most
people right that's most of us just
saying well this is just the way this is
this is just what in this book is it was
it's not just the way it is
it can be so much more it's a book about
hope man it's a book about
you got to deal with what happened so
that you can live a wild reckless
joy-filled life um yeah and then so that
is very important so they know live like
no one else so that so that you can live
and give like no one else and i'm really
excited what dave has done for people in
their financial life you're going to do
for people in their relationships their
mental health their emotional wellness
and i'm super pumped about this book
some people have gotten advanced copies
some of our listeners and they're going
nuts about it yeah it's pretty pretty
helping people already and if you
pre-order today ramsay solutions.com for
just 20 bucks you're gonna get the
audiobook version read by john himself
the e-book version and on top of that
one month of free weekly therapy
sessions from our friends at betterhelp
that's a deal right there that is a d
i'm excited to dig in i've been waiting
for the audiobook so i'm one of these
guys that i listen on 1.25 speed while
following along in the physical book and
i feel like i'm cheating the system i
was told recently somebody wrote into my
show and said you're the one podcast i
have to listen to at 1x speed because
you talk so fast
and that made me happy they slowed you
down on the audiobook so we could all
understand that's right i love it well
pumped about this book go check it out
ramseysolutions.com own your past change
your future that puts this hour of the
ramsay show in the books my thanks to my
co-host dr john deloney to james kelly
zack everyone in the booth keeping the
show afloat and you america thank you so
much for listening we're going to be
back with you before you know it
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramsey solutions
three
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your mental
health your relationships and so much
more i'm ramsay personality george
campbell joined today by dr john delony
some call the dream team some call it
the nightmare you get to choose america
this is your show we're taking your
calls triple eight eight two five five
two two five that is the number triple
eight eight two five five two two five
karen has decided to join us in la
crosse wisconsin karen welcome to the
show
hello nice to talk to you guys you as
well how can john and i help
well
i'm 54.
my husband's 58 we're in baby step
number two
um my mom fell a couple years ago and we
moved into her house with her to help
her
ended up too much for us so she went to
assisted living
she's not doing very well she will be
passing here
soon um
the house is in my name my brother and
my sister's name mom and dad put it in
our names
decades ago
the house has paid off
like i said we live here my brother
and sister are expecting us to buy it
because we live here and we have always
rented
so that's why we were the ones that
moved in with mom when she got sick
um
i i the way the market is
my
my third would have been taken off the
house so i would only pay two thirds of
what the fair market value is
but i'm trying to pay off debt i don't
know if i should take the money for the
house
and just pay the debt down and look
for a house because we wouldn't have
anywhere to live
or
buy the house okay um a couple of things
here
first exhale okay can you do it just a
big exhale
yeah
so
you've been living with your mom y'all
made a family sacrifice
yes to the outside world um you all had
a benefit too you have to pay rent for a
few years
anybody who's done what you did knows
that is not a dollar for dollar trade
because you
have been watching your mom slowly
decline and that takes your soul from
you okay so what you've been
experiencing is hard and now you're here
up against the end
and
you're about to go through grief and you
know it right so there's all this stuff
going on here and one of the things we
do when we are
find ourselves in a situation where we
are are out of control we have no
control over what happens next is we
start trying to grab for control and
what you're doing right now is you're
creating narratives and problems to
solve that aren't today problems those
are next month problems right now i want
you to be focused on
honoring your mom their last few days in
the last few moments and then we're
going to move into okay
let's sit down with brother and sister
and say here's my financial situation
can we rent for six months before we
save this up or what is your expectation
how quick do we have let's put this all
in writing so that everybody's
comfortable
and then we're gonna make a plan to move
forward okay is that fair we'll walk you
through the plan the finances but i want
that to to be
i know it's a pressing thing but right
now you're trying to figure out
something to do with those with that uh
energy
and that energy is best spent sitting
there holding your mom's hand and just
breathing heavy and saying this sucks i
hate this i'm gonna miss you yeah
okay
so
with your brother and sister
the the day after the funeral
are they going to say where's our check
where's our check
no no
okay
so do you have
uh you're y'all are busting it through
baby step two and george can walk you
through all of the nuances there the how
much do you make and all that but
ultimately are you going to be able to
afford to buy this house at some point
soon
yes we'll be able to make the payments
yes and and still work the baby steps
okay all right
i'll turn over to george yeah so what's
your household income
90 okay and how much debt are we talking
about 60 000
what kind of debt is it
a truck and a camper
well
how do you feel about the truck in the
camp
could we get rid of that
could we be debt-free by the end of this
weekend
husband would never go for it for both
he wouldn't even get rid of one of them
no husband is willing to
the husband is willing to consider
moving out of a house that you're going
to walk into with 33 equity on day one
because he just loves this this big boy
camper
and this his big boy truck
yeah i i
i guess did he play high school football
no
no he did he grew up really poor
and he i mean not that we're rich now
that's for sure but
does he care about paying the stuff off
yeah he does why all of a sudden
why at 58 does he care
yeah
yeah
i found you guys
six months ago yeah okay and i i
i would um if you sold them would you
have a
net result there positive
is it worth more than the loans
in this market i don't know i don't know
i guess so here's what i want you to do
i think so i think i think it probably
would be that the camper is only a year
old i i
my buddy just sold his camper that was
four or five years old and he ended up
getting more money than he bought it for
four or five years ago
i would if i was you
i would sit down and run the numbers
through kelly blue book
make a couple of phone calls and just
find out
if there's a chance that y'all could be
debt free today which is going to allow
you to
go ahead and buy your mother's house
and have a home y'all can then have a
24-month plan to buy a fancy camper and
a truck back
right i mean
this is a magic moment to flip the
script how much money do you guys have
in cash and savings in your accounts
uh we have about 30 grand in the account
right now and that's just 30 000.
why isn't that being applied towards the
debt
the husband doesn't want to touch it
okay so he's not he's not on board with
the plan he's on board with his plan
yeah what do you guys have in retirement
about 30 grand 30
300 000
okay 300 000 okay well i want you guys
to happen another thing i'm worried
for sometimes you're worried about
paying the house off and
what's this house what's this house
gonna be worth yeah
i i'm not sure um the
the taxes say 185 is the appraisal but
fair market value
god knows that's what my sister said she
wants yeah okay
well i'm getting rid of this debt asap
and i want you guys to get in this house
that seems to be your biggest goal it
doesn't seem to be his biggest goal and
until it's all's goal collectively yeah
this none of this is gonna happen it's
gonna create relational issues financial
issues and so we need a plan there and
then we need to plan with the siblings
about what this is gonna look like what
does this picture look like how long do
we have maybe to rent until we can
actually save up enough to where this
house isn't a burden but it's a blessing
so there's a real possibility with if
you sit down and do the math and sit
down and tell them honey i'm scared
i'm scared about losing my mama i'm
scared about us not having a house and
we're almost 60.
we have a magic moment to clear this
whole thing up we're gonna send you i'm
gonna give you a year's subscription to
ramsey plus to watch all the fpu videos
but you have to watch them with your old
man with your husband you all do this
together and you can change everything
starting right now
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's bethel betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsey show in
case you didn't know i'm george campbell
joined today by dr john deloney and we
are taking your calls triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
may is joining us up next she's in
raleigh north carolina may welcome to
the show
hi thank you for picking my call how are
you doing today great how can we help
um so i have a question which is more um
not really baby steps because we are
financially free um
incomes are i think about 70 and he
makes almost 50 000 so let's say 148
here okay who is
this my partner okay cool
yeah so i um i'm currently a nurse in
icu and i want to go to anesthesia
school
however i cannot get over the idea of
going to an ivy league honestly is such
a household to go through because
i went to undergrad for free um
by marriage got scholarships all the way
through and then like applied for some
on the way so i came out with you again
when i met him he had some debts so he
claimed the death so that we could you
know go forward and do stuff with our
lives but i'm at that point where i'm
like i really really want to go to an
ivy league school um because you want to
go to an ivy league school
yeah so
here so may i've spent my entire career
working at universities i even did a a
development program at harvard okay so
i've been there i love it tell me why
you have that picture in your mind that
you can't get out of your mind
i think uh
so i came as an immigrant and i think
when i was coming in
i missed the opportunity to do that
undergrad and so you know i kind of like
make the grades so that
when i do decide to go back to school
for the graduate level that i could be
able to do that
um but he is not buying the idea and
it's like well so secret desire well so
so tell me what
is your dream to be an extraordinary
nurse an anesthetist
yes okay and um let's see are you all
gonna do you have plans to make your
home and your family and to do life in
back in raleigh
um yes
in north carolina okay
if you told me
i really want to be
an anesthesia research scientist
i want to swan dive into the biochemical
physiology of
of
being of anesthesia i want to know how
the body responds i want to be around
the best scientists in the world
then maybe maybe depending on the
program
that type of capital outlet paying that
price would be worth it
what you want to be is a great
nurse who sits with people who are
scared and you're calling you have a
calming voice i could tell that you're
kind and you care about people
you want to go do good work on the lives
of people
and so there are a
whole bunch
a whole bunch of relatively inexpensive
that's not true they're expensive but
not as expensive programs
closer to your home and here's the thing
as an immigrant to this country you've
been given a picture that is partially
true
if you get this degree it somehow
completes you it's somehow by it somehow
proves that fill in the blank
that you should be here that you've got
value that you're smart enough and i
want to tell you that's nonsense now i'm
also not going to be one of those guys
that i see him on youtube and whatever
ivy league schools are stupid they're
not
there's a lot of real smart people there
i've sat with them brilliant people
incredible resources they're great and
i've also sat with some mind-bendingly
extraordinary people at local community
colleges
and especially at local state college
and at private faith-based universities
i've sat with them all
and so depending on what you do and why
you want to do it that's how i'm going
to decide if that's the school for me
and what you want to do is serve and
love people and so i want you to do that
with no debt in your there's there are
some killer colleges by the way in the
raleigh north carolina in the research
triangle you know that they're great
you are worth getting through college
and not having a bunch of debt and
you're worth getting a great education
and you can do that right where you are
okay so don't buy into the myth you
should not do it and by the way your
husband called in and asked me to tell
you this
i'm just kidding he didn't at all i'm
just kidding so may you're asking if you
have the cash is it okay to do it
yeah he wants us to buy a house and i'm
just like but i really really want to do
this and no no it's 50 000 we could pay
for 50 grand
well a house is an appreciating asset
you're going to live in that house it's
an appreciating asset that student loan
is a piece of paper that no one's going
to ask you about until you have to weave
it into the conversation very naturally
well and here's the other thing
the degree a graduate degree to become a
nurse anesthesiologist i can even make
an argument that's an appreciating
investment
do it with cash
do it with cash and do it for the right
reasons that's exactly right do with
cash
here's the thing if you sit down and say
hey look um when i factor in what's
going to cost to
us to cash out our 140 000 year jobs to
move to cambridge for um three years for
this program
and
you can put that together in cash i'm
not going to be sad about it
but if you can keep your 140 000 your
dollar your jobs and your current
workplace will help pitch in for some
tuition reimbursement to a college there
in raleigh of which there are some great
ones
um and you're going to keep it going do
it just do it you're worth more than an
ivy league certificate you are freaking
may from raleigh and you did it
and you're gonna go make it happen love
it thanks for the call man i appreciate
it deanna's up next in tucson arizona
deanna welcome to the show
hi guys how's it going great how can we
help
good um so i have my question today is
my husband and i we bought a house last
june
and it's our first house that we bought
we started listening to the show back in
january
um
our house value has gone up almost about
like a hundred thousand dollars
so we're wondering if we should sell our
house to pay off our debt and just rent
temporarily how much that do you have
we have about well we just paid off 2
000 so we have about 58 000 in debt and
it's student loan credit card debt
personal loan the whole nine yards okay
what's your household income
we make about 125 a year together okay
great so what does your plan look like
to get rid of this debt how fast right
now can you do it
um so right now based on our
calculations it's going to take us we're
considering getting second jobs right
now but um based on our just regular
it's going to take us about four years
okay i'm getting the second job and i'm
gonna get that cut down to two years and
if you can do that i'm not selling the
house
that's a big move there's a lot of costs
associated with it you haven't been in
there for two years so there's going to
be some capital gains tax it's not as
clean of a break as you think it is to
just get rid of the debt and let's do
this leapfrog shortcut i'm not mad at
selling a house to get out of debt and
renting for a little while and it's very
noble and i love that sacrifice but i
think you guys can do this with a 125
000 income and fifty eight thousand
dollars in debt we can clean this up in
two years it may take getting a second
job it may take doing the monthly budget
really dialing that in getting all of
our expenses down to bare bones for a
short period of time because here's the
thing four years it's a long slog for
you guys to sacrifice
24 months yeah okay i can do a second
job for 24 months hey will you do me a
favor
take that nuclear
energy
that is currently pulsing in your chest
and your husband's chest which is the
regret and the are we idiots and i can't
believe we did
take that and don't run
don't run from the problem
go gazelle intense right into the middle
of it okay running from it is okay let's
just sell our house and call it good and
whoo
don't do that because that's not solving
the problem that's a band-aid you're not
going to change your behavior i want you
to grind it out for 24 months and not i
want you have a second job and probably
a third hustle on the side of that okay
and at the end of 24 months you and your
husband will never borrow money again
your kids won't borrow money their kids
won't borrow money because you all have
bled and you all sweat and you all have
argued over budgets and what's important
to your family
and now you've got this beautiful house
worth a whole bunch of money that's all
yours
great points there the housing market is
absolutely wild and everyone's gone we
should sell right now but then you got
to go buy at the top of the market or
rent at the top of the market and you're
back to square one change your better
deal with the behavior
good reminders there this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're back with more of the ramsey show
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john deloney
a lot of stuff going on out there in the
world and inflation is uh probably on
your mind and with inflation comes more
ways to get screwed more ways to get
scammed and one of those now involves
buy now pay later here's an article john
from fox business by now pay later
expanding to storefronts and gas pumps
that's right so buy now pay later has
become increasingly popular in recent
years expected to reach 680 billion
dollars in transaction volume across the
world by 2025. and as covid has forced
many consumers to shop online more the
use of buy now pay later
obviously began to rise so let's pay for
net let's pay next month for last
month's trip that's what we're seeing
buy now pay later provider zip formerly
quad pay has a partnership with chevron
allowing drivers to pay for their gas in
four installment payments over a six
week span
wow
this is scary john
yeah because you're still driving all
those other times
you're paying for gas that happened
three weeks ago but you filled up twice
since then and so you're now paying for
gas two weeks ago and a week ago
all to kick the can down the road we're
going to build quad pay some huge shiny
new buildings yep and their executives
are going to be driving a bunch of fancy
new teslas
because
we found ourselves at this mess and
clarna an affirm and after pay i mean
the list of companies just keeps on
growing who people who are getting in on
this and what's hilarious john not so
hilarious not so fun fact another
article from fox business says this more
than a quarter of consumers can't afford
their buy now pay later payments of
course that's right it's not magic debt
hammer survey found that 30 of
respondents have struggled to make their
buy now pay later payments and have
therefore had to skip paying a bill for
essentials utilities rent mortgage car
to avoid defaulting this is bad
if you can't pay for your four walls but
you're paying quad pay for your gas
you have a huge problem
and here's what i found john clark brags
on their website this is hilarious they
brag to the retailers that consumers
spend 45 percent more
when you include a buy now pay later
service on your website that's right
when under that 40 add to cart it says
10 easy payments right four easy
payments of ten dollars to pay for that
forty dollar item it's it's a
more subversive
um predatory practice for people who are
really desperate and struggling and it's
stealing from the least of these in our
communities and it's taking capital out
of low income communities it's taking
the the hard work i mean these people
are working themselves to death in these
hourly wage jobs and these type of
companies they're like payday lenders
except now it's much more sophisticated
it's fancy and
you don't have to have the shame of
driving into a pedi lender place and
walk in with your head held low and and
sign away you just got to push the
button when you mix all this debt with
convenient payment methods and
effortless i mean that's literally apple
pays tagline cashless made effortless
yeah they want it to be effortless think
less about what you're doing feel it
less
it it makes me ill because this is one
of those things that is
just preying on folks who are hurting
right now and i
hate it hate it hate it i hate it
and it doesn't hey there's the thing i
don't have i do none of us do we don't
have magic solutions for the gas pump we
don't have magic solutions for
inflation right now i mean the ship's
out in the out of the harbor right now
there's a couple of you got to earn more
or spend less or have some people in
your life that are generous that can
right
there's some hard decisions we all got
to make yep but this is predatory but
paying quad pay before your light bill
that's not okay don't do that fine
margin in your budget i don't care what
it takes stay away from these predatory
lenders
even though they're shiny and they tell
you that they want to create financial
freedom quote unquote for everyone
that's what they're using they're using
language like we would use right create
breathing room in your budget if you are
a person of means if you're not a person
stuck on the margins who's struggling
refuse to use these services because
they're making their money on the backs
of people who are broke and who are
hurting and who are left aside don't
support this crap i'm not gonna get
pisses me off man because it's it's
those like i can go do this and i'll pay
the bill next month and i'll go wow
that's expensive and i'll pay the bill
the month after that they're not going
to make any money off me
they're going to make money off those
who can't so let's don't support this
thing and it will implode on itself and
i hate it i hate it i hate it i hate it
these younger generations are the ones
falling for it and they see it like well
it's better than a credit card yeah
final pay later it's better than a
credit card i'm making my payments it's
a more predatory credit card i think
yeah
golly don't do it people avoid buying
out pay later at all costs and hey let
me say this if your company is based on
stealing from hurting people
stop
stop
stop
that's it i hope that worked i hope
after pay goes hey john we heard you on
the ramsay show we're shutting it down
one of their not their seniors because
they're tied in somebody riding to work
is gonna get a clip and they're gonna
know what they're doing is wrong yeah
they're gonna know what they're doing is
wrong and they're gonna say hey at least
i can't be a part of this right yeah go
check out the fine print episode on buy
now pay later that we did it was eye
opening we shared some stories we talked
to experts go check it out it's called a
firm clarinet after pay should you buy
now pay later taha joins us in
birmingham taha welcome to the show
yeah hi how are you great how can we
help
uh actually i wrote down
some notes ooh very prepared
we appreciate that
yeah as a guy who's rarely prepared for
anything i really appreciate somebody
who's prepared
thank you thank you so i'm currently in
high school i'm uh 17 years old
and uh always been a business guy
i always have business in my mind um 24
7 honestly
okay what's your question
and um
so a lot of people actually around me
keep telling me that this is almost like
a
unhealthy obsession
and i just wanted to know what you think
about that
if you are thinking about business 24 7
365 and you're not spending time with
your loved ones and you're not having
fun and you're not out working and
you're not working at a job where you've
got purpose then i think they're correct
it sounds like you're distracting
yourself from something
yeah well i do actually have a job right
now okay do you have joy in your life
um
sure sure describe it to me
um well it's more like
you know since i'm still in school i
don't really have a lot of options okay
so it's more like
i don't really mind what i'm doing but i
feel like after i actually become an
adult i'll be able to do things that i
enjoy
okay
one of the most common
myths that i i've spent my whole career
sitting behind closed doors with leaders
when the wheels have fallen off
and one of the most common myths is when
i get x dollar amount when i get x job
title when i get to be the head of x
company
whoo then i'm gonna have a blast then
i'll start filling the blank and that's
simply false it's not true now i don't
want to discourage you i have become i
was single-minded about getting my phd
in education that's all i thought about
it's all i read that's all i did i was a
lunatic about it and i worked in that
field and then when i was in the
counseling dude i'm i all i do it's all
i read until i think about it's the
podcast i consume it's my friends right
so i don't want to discourage your
passion and you going all in
but i do have to make time for
relationships and community and friends
i have to make time for laughter i have
to make time for exercise and eating
right and going to bed
right and what i would tell you at 17 so
here let me give you this analogy
um some friends of mine i've spent most
of my career in universities and i've
made close friends with
the trainers the physical trainers for
the athletic teams and one of the things
they told me over the last five to 15
years is they've seen a shift in the
athletes coming in and these are 18 and
19 and 20 year old athletes
that have
joint disorders that are common in uh
the elderly
because since the age of five they've
been a pitcher
and they've gone to pitching camps and
they've gotten pitching coaches and they
don't play basketball they don't kick
soccer balls they don't run around they
pitch and they pitch and they pitch and
by the time they're 19 their shoulder is
completely blown out
so why do i tell you that
some of the great physiologists are now
saying hey don't let your kid just play
one sport all the way through make them
play soccer too make him take jiu jitsu
make him go to wrestling make him play
the violin right do these other things
so i want you to be focused on business
and i want you to read fiction
i want you to go to a movie and see how
your business looks in um in the in like
in a script like an actual relationship
i want you to have friends i want you to
go laugh and enjoy your life you have
plenty of time to get that job and to
make a bunch of money and make a
business but make sure you live and
breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so now we still have our granddaughter
yes yes we do okay all right
um so
we are flipping to a blank page
and want to know
i want to know how to plan properly for
her
because
we will be seven in our 70s when she
graduates from high school
if if we're still living i hope we are
but it changes the game plan i guess for
me and
we
feel like we're we're not on such of an
emotional rollercoaster anymore
my husband and i are on the same page
but it doesn't look
the retirement doesn't look the same as
what we had anticipated so
any advice yes yes okay so the first
thing that's important for you and your
husband to do okay
is is it gonna sound counter-intuitive
but if you may have already done this
but i want you to go away for a weekend
i want you to have one of your other
kids or a babysitter keep your
four-year-old down
and i want you all to grieve what was
you had a picture of retirement you've
been working really hard
clearly some things you and i could talk
for an hour and you could tell me what
the whole backstory here
but i want you to grieve what's what is
going to be different now
we were going to we were going to get a
lake house we were going to travel we
were going to fill in the blank
and now we might do some of that but
it's going to look different because we
have um we're raising our granddaughter
we have another kid in the house and
here's why that's important if you don't
the tendency is to roll this
fatigue
and the natural oh what about this and
we should it's gonna roll into
resentment and this little four-year-old
does not deserve that so four-year-old's
been through a lot and this isn't
something you're gonna do on purpose
this is just gonna be you trying to get
to the next day and the next day the
next day and when you tell your body
when you sit down and grieve something
and you say we wanted it to be like this
and it's not then your body goes oh
you're driving cool
and now we can start making plans for
what is this going to look like for us
okay so i want you all to own it and i
want you to be mad be mad at your at
your kid
you can be frustrated at the situation
get all of those feelings and put them
on the table they're all real and they
all have biochemical responses to them
cortisol and adrenaline all kind of
stuff and then you can be about um
here's what comes next what are we going
to do next and we're not going to try to
reclaim what was we're not going to try
to patch work this thing together you
and your husband are going to create a
whole new picture of what life's going
to look like now and by the way my mom
is 72
she's a gangster she's a college
professor she's
she's hilarious she flies all over the
world my dad is 71 he's
just finished being a cop and now he's a
college professor
he's goof like you're gonna be great
okay you're gonna be great
um
think of this as an adventure and how
can we put inject joy into this
situation not well it's just gonna not
be what it was do you hear what i'm
saying
right and i know that's hard that's why
i want you to go grieve this thing i
want you to go grieve it and sit in it
and let this go
and then you've got the financial part
that george can walk you through here's
how to set this thing up financially
it's going to be important that you get
some
um women in your life who are
10 or 15 years younger than you that
have young kids that will
let let your new child go on adventures
with them and go visit with them and all
these things right um so you're gonna
have to just get some help and you're
gonna have to get some support and
you're gonna have to be honest hey i'm
tired and i need some a break this
weekend i need one of my other kids to
step up or a friend or a babysitter
you're just gonna have to do it
differently and you're gonna have to be
honest about your limitations
and you're just gonna have to be
intentional about it
that sound like a lot i hear you're
getting quiet
in the last four years i know i know i
know
are you guys doing okay on the financial
side retirement do you have the money to
to raise her
and also take care of yourself
every all of that i mean we are um solid
ramsey people i guess you could say
you know and
is this little one is she your
son's child daughter's child
daughters okay
i may be way off
but often when i have this conversation
part of the the angst part of the
heaviness
is that somehow you think you screwed
something up
that if you had oh yeah we've been all
over that i know you have and you got to
set that brick down stop carrying it
what you have done is you've saved a
little girl's life
and you're giving this little girl an
opportunity to be with family and to
have a wild fun adventure with two wise
people who might not be able to get in
the go-karts but we can take you and
your friends there right um our hips and
knees can't handle it but
right and
you gotta set the bricks of what did we
do wrong down
okay and you got to be about living yeah
i think i think a lot of it is we uh i
i'm gonna speak for me because my
husband's not here
i still hold a lot of anger about the
entire situation i know and that's why i
want you all to go get it out go sit and
not get it out but go grieve it right go
own it go sit with it yeah
otherwise it will eat you alive and it
will end up in the heart of that little
girl
okay right and i don't i don't want that
at all i know i know i know i know yeah
can i tell you she's lucky to have you
she's so lucky to have you
do we draw it up this way no
but this little girl won the lottery
with you and your husband you all been
planning dave's print job at 11 days
principles for not if but when things go
sideways things went sideways and thank
god y'all had been living
you had been living this path for a
moment just like this
this is why we do it right this is why
we do it
that's why we do it stacey the fact you
guys
what yeah well the fact that you follow
these principles and you get to provide
this kind of life for her i mean that's
going to be a special thing and i know
right now it's hard to see that future
but i'm cheering you on as you guys
continue this journey and you get to
have a really cool story and it's not
the one you chose but it's when you get
to live and i'm i'm personally excited
for all the upside here i mean thinking
about having my amazing grandmother who
still just celebrated her 90th birthday
we went to boston and i love her to
pieces and to be able to live with her
and live that life with her be raised by
her that's something really special
and so you're going to start at 5 29
right you're going to get start saving
for college you're going to go back back
to
following the principles here you're
gonna make sure that this little girl's
got uh you know the four walls y'all
gotta have that taken care of we're
gonna do all the stuff that you normally
would do
it just happens to be with a
four-year-old now right
right and a lot of this is creating a
picture
so do we slow down
on our
because i mean i've got it i wouldn't
you're two years away right now you're
two years away i wouldn't because
not having a house payment at how old
are you now
in 57 yeah not having a house payment
before your 60 is going to allow you to
cash flow a lot of this stuff on the
back and you're fine
that's what i would do i finished the
plan you're almost there
you're almost there i'm so proud of you
and i'm so grateful that people like you
and hearts like you and your husbands
exist in our communities to take care of
the little ones
that run into messes that they didn't
start um so grateful for you it's gonna
be a wild adventure yeah back if you
need anything stacy we are here for you
appreciate the call that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books my
thanks to john deloney my co-host all
the folks in the booth and you america
we'll be back with you before you know
it but in the meantime make sure you're
spending wisely saving intentionally and
giving generously
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you